foreign
[Music]
spoilers show I'm your host Paul aka the
guy who always wants to put a smile on
that face and this video we're breaking
down terrifier too the ending of the
movie has a lot to impact from it and
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over the plot post-credits scene
and also giving our thoughts on the film
the series follows a killer clown who
makes murder a work of art the cloud
what now the previous film opened with
us seeing a TV interview in which the
host talked to a severely disfigured
woman she was the sole survivor of an
attack that took place on Halloween and
we learned that the killer was
masquerading as a clown he was caught
but his body mysteriously disappeared
from the morgue which sort of sets at
the events that happened in this film
the rest of the movie then played out
these events in full with us watching
Arts stalking friends Tara and Dawn this
started a deadly game of cat and mouse
in which we watched Dawn get half off
her birthday suit in the Halloween sale
Taro is also shot several times and his
sister Vicky arrived to see what was
going on there were several people
killed but but if you're an idiot like
me who watched the second one before the
first one then that's basically what you
need to know for that Rod started to eat
Becky's face and he seemingly shut
himself as the police arrived he was
taken in the morgue where he came back
to life and he murdered the medical
examiner Vicky was revealed to be the
woman at the start and we know from the
beginning of the movie that she attacked
the interviewer that takes us in a
terrifier too and all of this backstory
kind of helps to flesh out the
post-credits scene picking up
immediately after the first one we join
art as he continues on his Killing Spree
we still don't really get it cleared up
as to what exactly he is but he's
definitely a supernatural entity that
might be the embodiment of evil his
attacks are linked with Halloween and
this is thought to be the one day of the
air in which the veil between our world
and the other side is at its thinnest
similar to Pennywise the cardigan infect
people's minds and this is seen in
Sienna's dream which ends up bleeding
into the real world this stream
perfectly embodies him as it seems
bright and happy initially but things do
start to take a darker turn and he may
be a demon or the personification of
evil or maybe even a Mythic being that's
lived forever carrying out attacks like
this because of this more Supernatural
things are needed to take him out which
we'll talk about later on in the video
now he seems to potentially even trap
The Souls of some of his victims too and
this is embodied in the pale little girl
only art in a select few can see here
and the first thing you probably want to
know is what the hell is up with her
there's a newspaper article that we see
collected by Sienna's father and this
details what happened with her nice
little Easter egg is that it's written
by Wes Torrance which could be a not to
wear his Craven and also Jack turns from
The Shining but I digress anyway the
article talks about a Halloween Carnival
which ten-year-old Emily crane attended
she ended up getting lost and as then I
progressed and the attractions closed
down her parents started to search for
her eventually her mangled body was
discovered and this was found in the
makeup trailer now it's important to
bear in mind that crane was the daughter
of two circus performers who he laying
in the article were in fact mimes
potentially art was linked with this too
and though I keep calling him a clown he
is more in line with a mime when we look
at his design he's officially called or
the clown but yeah just so I'd bring
that up and how the pale little girl is
linked to him we know from the first
film that his victim Vicky is also
carrying on his legacy in some ways she
survived the attack and is still in the
real world which I think is why he ended
up going to her Emily would have had to
take her the head and as she doesn't
actually exist in the way the people can
see her they need someone more tangible
this will be seen in Vicky which is why
I think the head ends up with her
instead of staying with Emily now
children have a weird attachment to art
with Jonathan constantly obsessing over
the murders and also serial killers wait
is the serial thing a serial killer but
never mind no answer the pale little
girl we don't learn too much about her
beyond that but it's likely she's been
with art ever since Emily's death in
some sick and twisted way she may have
obtained immortality and now be along
for the ride with art she can imitate
Jonathan's voice and potentially she's
also connected to them now Jonathan and
Sienna are still grieving the loss of
their father who died after crashing his
car we learned that he developed a fatal
brain tumor and that this caused him to
start to see Visions about the clown he
collected newspaper clippings of his
killings and also started to compile
literal art in order to defeat art
terrible pen again now we learned that
siena's been making a Halloween costume
based on the Fantasy character her dad
created and he also left it with a sword
that can take out the villain art starts
to stalk it and there are theories at
Siena can actually kill him she
seemingly comes back from the dead at
the end of the movie and it's possible
that she carries the same energy that
art does in another similarity the
Pennywise we discovered in the book it
that there was a cosmic space Turtle who
was the opposite of the Killer Clown
this is what helped the losers Club kill
the creature as it allowed them to
Channel A positive energy within that
acted as the Ying de pennywise's Yang I
think something similar might be going
on here with siena's Father learning of
the way to beat art you might have been
able to channel the opposite energy to
what makes him Immortal into the blade
and this is how Sienna is able to kill
him much like how Pennywise had the
turtle or has the Fantasy character that
Sienna ends up becoming her father's
brain tumor could have allowed him to
view higher forms of reality which is
when he saw not only art but also the
character Sienna becomes this is the key
to defeating him unless he passed in a
way to destroy him in the end which
Siena was able to embody I've even seen
theories that art himself might be
Sienna's father bear with me these
didn't out and out say that he was the
same but instead they stated that the
evil entity that is odd used his body as
a hose to carry out these killings her
dad then became aware of what was going
on which is why he started to collect
the clippings he would have nightmares
of what was happening when the creature
took over and these became his paintings
he wanted to defeat odd which is why he
did what he did but all this did was
kill him and allow the demon to fully
take over it's an interesting Theory and
it also explains why botherison and
daughter are the only ones that can see
the pale girl Siena being his one
weakness 2 could be linked with this but
let me know below if you have any other
theories I think your dad burning to
death would kind of negate this but
ought to be fair has come back from
worse now are once more startup is
killing spree and the Halloween attack
is so gory it would make Michael admires
the bloodshed
sake and there's lots of mind-blowing
kills that will make you slash your eyes
out and Jonathan is captured the blade
is taken by Art and Sienna's friends
ride out with her to the carnival where
Emily was killed eventually it leads to
a shutdown between the clan and Sienna
and when attempting to save her brother
art stabs her with the blade she falls
to the floor into the water tank that
appeared in her dreams and here she sees
scenes from the fantasy hitting that
this might actually be Art's domain here
she dies but the Stab Wound within her
starts to Glow along with the blade
perhaps her father's love was embedded
in this which is what brought her back
so that she could save her brother using
the blade she finally cuts off Art's
head having been healed now she had to
die in order to travel into this world
and it is possible that this is also how
Arts brought back after death he likely
goes there too which is where he's once
more returned to the land of the living
through tapping into Supernatural forces
he's beheaded at the end and the little
pale girl takes this with her this could
hint at Art coming back fully however
she may become the person that we focus
on from now as she seems to be being
told stuff it could have her carrying
the mantle of Art and there are other
people that may take this too that's
namely Vicky who we end up joining in
the film's post credit scene you see
that she's been confined to a mental
hospital and initially though the staff
say she's very calm this doesn't last
long you see her riding stuff into the
wall similar how art did and his stomach
swells up as she gives birth to his head
pretty mental and again this could be
him now traveling through his victims
and telling them to do things that will
continue his legacy he bit into her in
the first movie and this could have
trapped his Essence in here which is why
he doesn't die it's sort of a horcrux
situation with Jonathan potentially also
carrying this within him too it's a
similar thing to what he did with a pale
little girl and if we get a terrifier 3
then it could focus on Vicky and Emily
continuing his Reign it might break the
walls down now linking so bad now
linking back to the theory before about
Sienna's father a similar thing could
also be happening here if he was
indeedart's vessel then it may have
worked in a similar way with him guiding
someone to carry out his killings really
messed up way to end the movie that sets
up a sequel and I hope you enjoyed our
thoughts and our theories as for my
review I don't exactly think it's
Citizen Kane but there's a lot here to
like if you're fans of creepy characters
and over-the-top Gore I can't believe
how well they went with some of the
kills and though I can't show them here
they'll definitely stick in my mind for
a long time terrify 2 was a fun film to
check out in the aftermath of Halloween
and it's nice seeing indie horror like
this slowly building a following the
movie will absolutely not be for
everyone and some horror fans might even
find it a tough watch due to how gory
you get but overall I thought it was a
pretty wild ride I'm giving it a 7 out
of 10 and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it below we're running
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie
the winners will be picked at random on
the 15th and the last ones are on screen
right now save that to you message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch we've got a
breakdown on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor and see
you next time take care peace
[Music]